es ist ein gewaltiges verbrechen dass
hier offenbar geplant wurde ein
grundstück mitten im wald in asendorf
ist dass die niedersachsen razzia dort
schwer bewaffnete sek beamte die dieses
waldgrundstück gestürmt habe
spezialkräfte mit polizei panzer
hubschrauber in der luft
kampfmittelräumdienst am boden
zeitgleich dann auch zwei razzien noch
in hamburg dort in wohnung das ist die
jagd auf 200 kilogramm sprengstoff
200 kilogramm denn die sind weg einfach
verschwunden und sie sollten wohl einen
ganz schrecklichen plan dienen ja einem
anschlag einem gewaltigen anschlag auf
dieses stillgelegte atomkraftwerk in
lubmin bei greifswald jagd auf 200
kilogramm sprengstoff und ein gewaltiger
anschlagsplan also das ist das was wir
bisher über diesen fall wissen
was wir bisher wissen die razzia mit dem
panzerfahrzeug survivor stürmen
polizisten und sprengstoffexperten ein
waldgrundstück in asendorf niedersachsen
die elite polizisten durchsuchen zeit
leicht zwei wohnungen in hamburg
gesucht 200 kilo c4 composite compound
vor ein hochexplosiver
plastiksprengstoff der häufig vom
militär verwendet wird er ist 35 prozent
explosiver als tnt das c4 soll 2014 aus
einem militärdepot in dänemark gestohlen
und über die grenze nach deutschland
geschmuggelt worden sein der verdacht
nach unbewiesenen hinweisen sollte mit
dem c4 ein anschlag auf das stillgelegte
atomkraftwerk greifswald geplant worden
dritter ist uns jetzt zugeschaltete
logitech mit weiteren informationen zu
diesem fall befassen uns für uns einmal
zusammen es ist schon zehn tage her
warum hat es so lange gedauert
er vertritt sie ist eine sehr gute frage
normalerweise wenn so einer razzia läuft
dann erfährt man am selben tag oder am
nachfolge tag was ist hier eigentlich
passiert und was geht es ja eigentlich
bei der durchsuchung das war bei dieser
maßnahme einfach nicht der fall es gibt
bisher keine pressemitteilung es gibt
bisher keine informationen offiziell
warum hier dieses objekt durchsucht
worden ist und auch warum in hamburg
durchsucht worden ist und die polizei
ist auch hier mit sehr schweren geschütz
aufgefahren jetzt gerade im schon
gezeigt die bilder vor dem survivor
fahrzeug der wird nur eingesetzt wenn es
wirklich eine gefahr in verzug ist immer
mit gegenwehr rechnet und offenbar hat
man hier tatsächlich nach waffen gesucht
und aber auch noch sprengstoff gefunden
wurde aber hier erstmal nichts es wurden
zwar in hamburg waffen sichergestellt
noch munition
aber dieser gesuchte sprengstoff der ist
eben nicht aufgetauchten offenbar sind
auch nicht alle zielpersonen die
angetroffen werden sollten
aufgefunden worden ist nur eine person
festgenommen worden und das macht die
sache offenbar ein bisschen brisant und
deswegen laufen offenbar mit der grund
noch die ermittlungen weiter und
deswegen gibt es offenbar auch keine
offiziellen informationen dazu ja sehr
brisant dieser fall dank an unser bild
reporter gerd schröder und wir gehen
weiter zu dem sicherheitsexperten und
sprengstoffexperten alte russin ski
hierbei bild live größe sie herzliche
rutsch ins gewinn von 200 kilogramm
sprengstoff wie verschwunden sind also
man maxi kann ja auch mal wie das
überhaupt passieren konnte aber was ist
das für eine gigantische größe 200 kilo
sprengstoff was kann man damit anrichten
und seiner nächsten jahr tatsächlich
eine sehr große menge die dafür spricht
dass es eben wie auch schon vermutet
sich da um eine militärische herkunft
handelt denn so derart große mengen sind
eigentlich nicht verfügbar wir müssen
nicht vorstellen dass im polizeilichen
bereich von beispiel
sondereinsätzen oder auch militärischen
bereich wenige gramm reichen 50 bis 100
gramm um zb in der zue beschränkung
durchzuführen gegen ein tor oder gegen
eine gesicherte türen das aufzuspringen
wir anständig einem vielfachen zu tun
das heißt das deutet auf eine gewisse
gefährlichkeit hin wenn sich das
bestätigt das muss man ja auch immer
noch dazu sagen und das ist auch wenn
die ungewöhnlich oder das wäre
vermutlich taktisch ungewöhnlich wenn
hier geplant gewesen wäre wendelstein
geplanten bilden ist dass alle 200 kilo
dann gemeinsam zu sprengen gebracht
werden das sieht mir eher danach aus als
sei vielleicht gilt angedachten wir sind
verschiedene sprengen sitzen daraus
geborgen unglaublich wenn man sich ja
auch mal was auf jeden fall mit dieser
enormen menge alles möglich geworden
wäre im beitrag haben das gehört da
fällt immer wieder das wort c4 wofür
wird das genau genutzt
ja wie schöneberg habe es ist ein
überwiegend militärisch genutzter
sprengstoff ist der praktische
sprengstoff gehört zu den plastischen
nicht plastiksprengstoff das wäre das
falsche zeichen klassischer form machen
das heißt man kann das also ein bisschen
liegende knete in bestimmte formen
bringen zum beispiel konkav und konvex
und bestimmte sprengen richtungen zu
erzielen wird auch verschiedene
waschungen verwendeten zum beispiel in
internaten
aber auch natürlich eben als vorfahrer
sprengstoff der sich zum beispiel um in
rente gehen als spende
aufzusprengen dafür wird das taktisch
verwendet es ist ein sozusagen die sagen
wie die nato antwort auf sex gewesen was
ebenfalls ein formbarer sprengstoffs uns
der in den staaten des warschauer paktes
im kalten krieg entwickelt wurde
grundsätzlich basiert die vier auf achse
gehen das ist ein kraftvoller ebenfalls
militärs entwickelter sprengstoff und
insofern
wird die vier auch meistens
militärischen gelagert und entsprechend
auch gesichert in einzelfällen können
sie vom bergbau zum beispiel gibt es wie
so was einen dunklen marken schwarzen
markt also ähnlich dem drogenmarkt
beispielsweise und was was erzielt dann
sowas oder kleinere mengen davon
für preise auf an solchen markt
und märkte gibt es für eigentlich alles
auch natürlich entsprechend der
schwarzmarkt
natürlich gibt es auch für zu viel
allerdings ist es natürlich ist sehr
schwer heranzukommen das problem eben
ist auch dass die nachverfolgung von c4
sehr intensiv betrieben wird sich hier
daneben entdeckt werden bei sprengstoff
kontrolle durch spürhunde der stoff an
sich ist nicht absehbar aber es gibt
seit mehreren jahrzehnten beimischungen
von duftstoffen auch von metallspäne zum
beispiel um das sichtbar zu machen in
entsprechenden röntgengeräten die preise
sind variabel dabei da kann man jetzt
keine
belastbare aussage zu machen
grundsätzlich so angebot und nachfrage
und dann kommt es auch auf die
verfügbare menge an das kann natürlich
sein dass durch aktive kriegerische
auseinandersetzung der harz ein bisschen
sozusagen angebots getriebener wird das
sehen wir immer wieder mit kontexten da
muss man aber abzuwarten ob jetzt zum
beispiel im kleinkrieg dazu führt dass
die preise nicht so ein bisschen aber
dann plötzlich ein rohstoff danke an den
sicherheitsexperten und
sprengstoffexperten meint roschinsky
hierbei bild live in diesem
spektakulären fall in dem ja es ist so
viele rätsel gibt die jagd nach 200
kilogramm sprengstoff
[Musik]